As a young woman, I've had
some pretty cool opportunities.
One that I'm most proud of
is having my art displayed
at the DMA before I turned 17.
When I was in the auditorium
with all the other young artists
being honored for our achievements,
I couldn't think
of how proud I was of myself.
All I could think about
was the velvet upholstery of the chairs
touching the back of my arms and legs.
For me, the sensation
of touching velvet is unbearable.
You may be thinking,
"I don't like certain textures either,"
but there's more to this story
you need to know.
I’m Kate Kahle.
I’m 20 years old, and I’m autistic.
When I was a freshman in high school,
my family noticed that I was having
difficulty connecting with my peers.
I had also developed severe anxiety,
and it showed up in unexpected ways.
I had always had
autistic traits and struggles,
but I just thought I was weird.
My parents took me in for an evaluation
where we learned I was autistic.
We were all shocked
because I'm not what people
would typically think of
as an autistic person.
Autism is diagnosed
when social expectations
for neurotypical behavior
begin to outweigh the person's ability
to perform those behaviors.
Autism spectrum disorder, or ASD,
is a lifelong developmental disability
that can cause deficits in communication,
social interaction, emotional awareness,
and it can cause sensory issues
among other symptoms.
The reason it's lifelong is that autism
is not a disease and it can't be cured.
It's a neurodivergency,
which means that the autistic brain
works differently
than the neurotypical brain.
No one is sure
why some people have autism.
One of the criteria for diagnosis
is that symptoms must be present
from birth or early childhood,
which means that it's not caused
by poor diet, bad parenting,
vaccinations, and it's not contagious.
Evidence has shown that autism
can be passed down genetically,
which means it may run in families.
I found that a lot of neurotypical people,
and even some autistic people,
struggle with the concept
of the autism spectrum.
This is partially because
I think it's poorly named,
but also partly because
the way that experts and researchers
think about autism
is changing all the time
as they do more research.
In the past, autism had three categories:
mild, moderate and severe.
Later, it was thought of
more as a continuum like this,
from high-functioning to low-functioning,
with high-functioning
also being called Asperger's syndrome.
You may think that as long as a person
experiences the same symptoms,
what you call their disorder
doesn't matter.
Here's why I don't prefer
the term "Asperger's syndrome."
Hans Asperger was a medical doctor
and early researcher on autistic kids
who he called "autistic psychopaths."
He believed in eugenics,
and he sent many of the kids
that he worked with
to the Third Reich's child euthanasia
and sterilization programs.
While not the Nazis' main targets,
autistic people were considered a threat
to the Third Reich goal
of a genetically pure society.
When people use the term
"Asperger's syndrome,"
they're unknowingly reinforcing the idea
that autistic people
have no value to society.
This is why I prefer my disorder
be referred to as autism spectrum disorder
or autism instead of Asperger's syndrome.
Nowadays the spectrum
is thought of more like this.
This shows some of the struggles
that autistic people can have
and the varying degrees
to which each person can struggle
with those particular issues.
Autism can have many symptoms
and may vary widely from person to person.
Some symptoms you might think of
when you think of autism
are struggling to make eye contact,
poor communication,
sensory issues and obsessing
over special interests.
But there are also a lot of other symptoms
you might never have thought of before,
like heightened emotions,
making too much eye contact
or high affective empathy.
A lot of these less commonly
thought of symptoms
are more common
in women and girls with autism.
Here you can see a spectrum
that I filled out
to reflect my experiences.
As you can see,
I have lots of sensory issues
with textures and sounds,
I focus a lot on my special interests,
and I have high affective empathy
which allows me to easily
communicate with others.
After the initial shock of my diagnosis,
it began to make a lot of sense.
I finally realized why I had struggled
to pick up on other people's
negative emotions,
like when they're sad or frustrated.
This affected my relationships
for the first 15 years of my life.
I'm very grateful for my diagnosis
because it allowed me
to understand and accept myself,
and I was very lucky to get it.
For every four boys diagnosed with autism,
only one girl is diagnosed.
Studies that have followed
children since birth show
that the natural ratio of males to females
with autism is closer to three to one.
The discrepancy
between this diagnostic rate
and the actual rate of autism
between males and females
is likely due to the way
autism has been defined and studied
and the tests used to diagnose it.
The tests used to diagnose autism
are still based on studies
done on white autistic boys,
which likely leads to lower
and misdiagnosis in women.
I would like to add that this is not only
an issue for women, but also minorities.
White children are 19 percent more likely
than Black children
and 65 percent more likely than Hispanic
children to receive an autism diagnosis.
Males who outwardly display
mild symptoms of autism
are diagnosed on average two years earlier
than women who display similar symptoms.
This might be because
female special interests
are generally more socially accepted
than male special interests.
When nonautistic people think
about autism special interest,
the thing that usually
comes to mind is trains.
I've never had any interest in trains.
When I was a kid,
my special interest was in insects.
The people in my life saw this
as just a healthy interest
in the sciences,
and it was never really flagged
as an autistic trait.
While my special interests
were an autistic trait
that was largely ignored,
my other autistic traits were hidden
because I was skilled at masking them.
Masking is a behavior
by which autistic people try to camouflage
and seem like they're not autistic.
Hearing this for the first time,
neurotypical people might think
that autistic people are insecure
or manipulative
for trying to hide our symptoms.
This isn't true.
The real reason
an autistic person would mask
is because of a natural human desire
to fit in, connect with others
and achieve social
and professional success.
Masking behaviors can include
forcing eye contact,
mimicking others’ behaviors,
expressions and gestures
and even memorizing scripts
for small talk and common conversations.
Some people are more skilled
at masking than others.
I'm really good at masking
and people tell me that all the time,
whether they know it or not.
When someone says to me
that they never would have known
I was autistic if I hadn't told them,
or even that I don't seem autistic,
what they're really telling me
is that I'm good at masking.
A lot of people see this
as a really positive thing.
It's something that allows
me to live a "normal" life.
And while it's true
that some things can be easier
when people can't tell you're autistic,
it's impossible for a person with ASD
to not be heavily affected by it.
Autism is a part of us.
It colors the way we think,
interact with others
and see the world throughout our life.
This isn't something
that can be turned off with masking.
It simply gets pushed down
to a level below that
at which other people can see it.
This pushing down of our true self
takes a lot of work.
Think about this.
When you're having
a conversation with somebody,
you're doing a lot of things at once.
You have the correct posture
and the right distance away from them.
You're using the right facial expressions.
You're modulating your tone.
You might be gesturing.
You're making the right amount
of eye contact.
You're not not looking them in the eyes,
but you're not looking them
in the eyes so much that it's creepy.
(Laughter)
And you're predicting
what the other person
is going to say and do next.
For neurotypical people,
all of these things come naturally.
You guys don't even
have to think about them.
But for me, I have to think
about all those things at once.
Over the years, I've learned
how to juggle all of these things,
but it's a Herculean task,
and for some its complexity
makes it impossible.
The difficulty of masking can often lead
to secondary mental health challenges.
Depression can stem from working so hard
and still not being accepted,
while anxiety can come from the stress
of having to mask
for a good portion of the day,
every single day,
for a good portion of your life,
or risk being discriminated
against and ostracized.
These secondary mental health challenges
are of particular issue
for women and girls.
34 percent of women with autism
have depression,
and 36 percent have anxiety.
While these secondary
mental health challenges are a big issue,
the biggest problem
masking causes for autistic people
is late and misdiagnoses.
If someone is really good at masking,
they may never be diagnosed at all.
Men and children are the group
seen to be least skilled at masking,
and they're also the groups diagnosed
with autism spectrum disorder most often.
Case studies show that women
are more skilled at masking,
and this is likely a huge factor
that contributes
to their late and misdiagnoses.
The earlier a person
is diagnosed with autism,
the earlier they can receive
specialized care and treatment
that can help them
in almost every aspect of their life.
Care for autistic people
gets better all the time
as more research is done,
but unfortunately,
it's rare to find a therapist
or other people who assist autistic people
that recognize the extra challenges
that come with being a woman.
When you struggle socially as a female,
learning to succeed socially
as a male just isn't enough.
Womanhood is a unique and challenging
experience all its own.
The rules of female friendship,
how to talk about romance, menstruation
and even how to stay safe
from sexual predators
are all obstacles that autistic women face
but do not receive support for.
While it's tempting in our society
to say that gender is something small,
obsolete or insignificant,
the truth is gender does matter.
And when it comes to autism,
it matters a lot.
The difference comes in
with the vast disconnect between
the lived experiences of men and women.
All autistic people are born autistic,
but from birth, girls are thrust
into a more socially rigorous environment
that increases the pressure to mask
and the challenges
an autistic person faces daily.
For any autistic person,
but especially women and girls,
the part of their autism you can see
is not what that person
is actually experiencing.
It's impossible for someone
with a limited outside perspective
to label someone else's autism,
be that label "mild," "moderate,"
"Asperger's," "high-functioning,"
or any other label.
You can see me up here
right now talking to you
and try to label me to differentiate me
in your mind from another autistic person
you may have met,
such as maybe a little boy
having a sensory meltdown in the mall.
You can try to label me in your mind
to differentiate us,
but the feelings
that we're having on the inside
are probably more similar
than you would think.
I've just learned to mask them
after years of pressure and practice.
This is partially because
what society expects of a grown woman
is different than what they expect
from a little boy,
which is reasonable.
But society also expects more
of a little girl than a little boy.
From a young age, girls are expected
to have higher emotional intelligence
and care more about
their peers' emotions than boys.
This is reinforced in almost
every aspect of their life,
from TV shows and toys to the words
and actions of family and teachers.
Women are better at masking
because society expects more from us,
and it doesn't make
as many allowances for us.
Sometimes society will make exceptions
for the social deficits of autistic men
in exchange for
the knowledge and perspective
they can bring to the table.
But it won't do the same thing
for autistic women.
I want you to walk away
from this auditorium
knowing that autism is not a disease,
and it doesn’t need to be cured.
It's just a different way
some brains can work.
If you want to help autistic people,
you can support organizations
like Autistics for Autistics,
Autistic Self Advocacy Network
and Autistic Women and Nonbinary Network
that support autistic self-love
and acceptance,
as opposed to organizations
that spread fear about autism.
You should also identify yourself
as an autistic advocate
to people in your life.
Be understanding and allow friends
and family to unmask with you.
This is also a call to action
for the psychology community
to conduct more research
on autism in women,
people of color and other minorities.
Most of all, I want you to know
that every person
with autism is different.
I got up here today
to share my perspective
because I'm not what a lot of people
would think of as an autistic person.
But that doesn't mean
that every woman with autism
will have the same or even
a similar experience to mine.
My autism journey
is just one out of thousands
that can provide insight
into the way autistic people think,
interact with our society
and see the world.
Thank you.
(Applause)